make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are picking up with
annihilation conquest and I know I've
been talking about doing the story for
quite some time honestly I just kind of
want to cover it and just sort of have
fun with it right like not really
worried about the accounts just more
worried about having a good time and
that the cool thing about this is that
anihilation conquest comes hot off the
heels of annihilation and when I say hot
off the heels I mean maybe it's been a
couple months since annihilation ended
if that that's basically it right now
for those you guys who don't know about
annihilation make sure you check the
link in the description that'll get you
all the videos for annihilation and kind
of get caught up but essentially that
pushed the universe almost to the
complete and total brink of destruction
and and that's kind of what you have
here that in a lot of ways throughout
the entirety of the universe you kind of
have these empires right you have the
Kree you have the scrolls you have the
Shiar you have like these multi you know
these these interplanetary empires are
sort of rule these giant sections of the
universe and the result of that is that
after the events of annihilation that
like you you have kind of what's
essentially sort of a no-man's land now
one of these territories that were
previously being policed by the various
empires are not being policed anymore
because the resources just aren't there
right because so many lives were lost so
many militaries were decimated different
things along those lines and so what
you're met with are a handful of pirates
who basically show up at a temple of the
priests of Palma and the idea is to
basically just steal some stuff the idea
is just to loot that's really all it is
so like loot some valuable artifacts and
then sell them out to people and that's
really kind of the way things get done
now unfortunately this group is
essentially met by the arrival of file
of they'll now file eval is a character
that we have never really talked about
here on comics explained and file eval
is actually one of the coolest
characters in the history of Marvel she
is amazing right because for for a lot
of the modern readers who were basically
reading you know in like 2004 2005 2006
they kind of followed the introduction
of her character going forward so final
valve originally had her introduction
and the second volume of Captain Marvel
and we're not talking about the one that
applies to Carol Danvers instead this
version of Captain Marvel focus on
genous valve and the idea is that that
genus Val is essentially the son of the
original Captain Marvel marvel of a
creep the issue here is that Marvel
didn't really have genus Val while he
was alive the idea was that Marvel had
fallen in love with in an artificial
being by the name of alyssia's who had
actually been created it's kind of a
back-up plan by Isaac when Thanos had
basically screwed up
programming and so on kind of weird
doesn't really matter the overall gist
of this is that after Marvel died that
Alyssia siddhis had used some of
Marvel's DNA to artificially inseminate
herself and then gave birth to jeana's
fell the issue is that over the course
of Captain Marvel vol 5 the genus val is
real it was really kind of hit with this
idea from from alyssia's that like he's
essentially a poor man's marvel right
he'll never be the man his father was
right and so over the course of that
story jeana's Val ends up going crazy he
ends up kind of wiping you know
destroying reality and then remaking it
and when that happens alyssia's ends up
having a file of el neil - to really
kind of combat Marvel and replace him
and so once everything had gone back to
normal because this whole reality
warping thing was not a huge crossover
it was strictly in the pages of Captain
Marvel so I wouldn't be surprised if you
missed it but once everything is set
back to normal file eval is one of these
characters it's kind of slip streamed
into them the main Marvel Universe kind
of brought in is everything sort of
collapsing which Marvel's done that
before why they did with like heroes
reborn they did it with like Age of
Apocalypse they've done that multiple
times but she's basically kind of
brought in and then the result is that
she's basically been here ever since now
originally she was given the mega bands
but more recently she is she's in
possession of the quantum bands now the
quantum bands traditionally belong to
quasar right they originally belong to
Wendel Vaughn and the idea behind the
quantum bands is they tap into the
quantum zone or the quantum realm
whatever you want to call it that's the
reason why during the events of infinity
war and Avengers in game and during
ant-man when there was all this talk
about like the quantum realm and things
like that people were saying okay so
like now we're gonna get the quantum
bands we're gonna get quasar like this
that's where people were getting all
that from because that the band's tap
into that realm of energy and
essentially the the quantum zone as it
existed back then it was essentially a
place whereby all matter and energy
originated in the formation of the
Marvel Universe that sense changed but
basically it's just an exceedingly
powerful source of energy now is it
really allow her to like become God
there are limits and in a lot of ways
the limits are her imagination but the
issue with file eval if she's currently
learning what it is that she can do with
these band the reality is that she's
basically new to all of this right now
the other part of this is that file eval
is also accompanying by moon dragon now
with the Captain Marvel vol 5 line of
stories the way this played out is that
after genus val was basically defeated
and it all came to an end this story
shifted its focus to file eval they kind
of followed me or documented her
experience and like becoming the new
captain
you know that you know whatever it is
and then ultimately becoming the new
quasar basically I kind of undertaking
that role in going forward but during
issue number 25 she met moondragon and
the two fell in love and they've kind of
been they were you know up to this point
they were kind of a little bit of a
couple the issue is that you got like
you got like that issue and then like
annihilation popped off so there wasn't
really a whole lot of time to explore
where this relationship could go but in
the aftermath of annihilation that's
what they've been doing is exploring
their relationship you know figuring out
whether or not they work as a couple
different things like that and they do
and in fact in the modern era of comics
moondragon and file Lavelle is actually
one of they're actually one of the most
popular coming but couples that are out
there so what this does is it switches
over to holla the Kree homeworld
now holla was really like the
militaristic Empire in Marvel Comics
right and that's really reasons why
you're sort of getting things like the
war of Kings right you get the war of
Kings story because the Shiar in the
Kree we're basically like the two
military empires that existed out there
you have the scrolls
well the scrolls are really kind of like
a hodgepodge ragtag group of people who
were dicks that's basically what they
were and so they were they were barely
holding it together they had their
empire but they weren't nearly on the
same kind of militaristic level as they
as the Kree or the or the Shiar and they
weren't nearly as mobilized and
organized but with everything that's
gone on that you essentially have Peter
quill who's sort of been brought in here
and the reason why this matters is
because Peter quill is in a lot of ways
an advisor for the Kree Empire
especially because of his role in during
the events of annihilation him and Anne
Richard Rider were basically running
what was left of like this survivors
right those planets that hadn't been
conquered it was like like the unified
defensive front or something like that
but basically like as the annihilation
wave was making its way across the
universe conquering world after world
after world it was literally just like
like Peter quill and and Richard rider
just fleeing for their lives in trying
to like launch guerrilla warfare tactics
fight where they could when they could
right so it was like humans versus
Skynet is really what it was like with
these guys and so as a result of that
you know because of the fact that they
proved to be successful and because it
was really in a lot of ways Peter quill
that kind of helped to keep the whole
United Front going on with the Kree he's
really kind of a kind of consider like
an ambassador or an advisory specific of
the entry military bases kind of been
put under Peter quill and so far that
what they're doing is reaching out to
the gala Dorian space Knights
now the gala Dorian space Knights are
are literally just like robot Knights
right and there are people who can
convert themselves into robots basically
a kind of artificial intelligence
more or less and then like go forward
it's kind of like protectors across the
universe what this meant is that given
how organized and how structured and
because of the fact that most of most of
the the gala Dorian space night I guess
organization and structure runs on a
super enhanced battlenet what the Kree
are looking to do is to take that
technology and apply it to their own
military and apply to their own
centuries right because the centuries
are a huge portion of the fighting force
right the robots centuries of the creek
are a huge portion of the fighting force
they do have their own biological
soldiers write their own organisms their
own Kree soldiers much like we as humans
have our own human soldiers they do have
those but it's much much easier to
create a whole bunch of centuries and
then make them make it into cannon
fodder right just set them out there for
every one century soldier that's
destroyed another ones being created
whereas you can't just like create a
member of the Kree race in the span of
like an hour or two you cannot create
them that fast and so because of this
you know where you have you know Richard
Rider and and and Peter quill kind of
talking to each other that what you end
up getting here is the arrival of the
gala dorium space Knights and when they
show up here of course Daystar is the
one that basically starts talking to
everybody and just kind of okay so let's
go ahead and let's get with yet with the
system being brought online and it's
really really cool because the gala
dorium software it basically has the
ability to enhance the performance of
the Kree military surface to you know on
a geometric rate basically saying like
we can tie them all together we can have
them all operate almost with a singular
consciousness and they all just sort of
go forward and they achieve a certain
goal right so it's like if you had like
if you had 15 people who all had the
ability to think the same way like to
think with a singular mind and then
function you know and perform a
particular task it would be done at a
far more efficient rate right as opposed
to like everybody kind of doing things
their own way and so as a results of
that when the when the battle system is
brought online everything is just sort
of you know seems to be going
exceedingly well the issue with this is
that once the battle Nets brought online
you jump over to a to fire level and
moon dragon for a second and they're
immediately attacked by a crease century
now one thing to understand about the
Kree centuries is they do use them as a
garrison right so like if the Kree show
up to a particular planet or a location
and they say okay this place is of
interest not enough interest for us to
like station and entire you know platoon
here or something like that but enough
for us to leave a couple centuries you
know to kind of monitor our interest and
make sure nobody takes them over and
that's what they'll do and that's what
they did here right in this instance
where you have File of L and moon dragon
there was a Kree sentry being stationed
there and the Kree sentry a me
goes awry and starts attacking
everything from that point that's
exactly where everything starts to fall
apart that what Peter quill and the
various military scientists start to see
is incompatibility they start seeing
that essentially something's taking over
the entire battle neck and where's kind
of like what the world's going on like
we have to shut it off maybe it's some
kind of software glitch or something
like that the gala dory and space
science are basically saying like there
is no glitch here this is functioning
exactly as intended we must all join
together we have to eliminate those who
will not freely join essentially what's
happening is the entire cream
military-industrial complex is being
completely and totally taken over by the
gala Dorian space Knights the funny
thing about this is the gallery of space
Knights or not the ones running the show
they're not the ones pulling all the
strings
the ones who are pulling all the strings
are gonna blow your mind and I guarantee
you it's not the ones you're gonna see
at the end of this video the reveal that
comes with this story was a mare using
like when you find out what's actually
going on here it was one of the best
reveals ever right like a lot of you
guys probably know what happened please
don't spoil anything let's just live in
the moment you guys know how I like to
do things and so as a result of that of
course with the Kree century being
destroyed it lets off kind of a you know
a kind of blinding amount of energy but
what you also have here what you also
kind of have going on or a few things
for file eval you have this kind of
disembodied voice that's communicating
with her or simply saying the Kree
Empire is going to fall there's only one
being that can save them and everything
else in existence you have to find that
Savior right she kind of gets this
disembodied voice appearing to her and
telling her this the other thing is that
the Kree I guess the various Kree
centuries begin to kind of meld together
and when I say meld together I mean like
they all they all it's not like a Rat
King
right we're all just kind of lucid like
they're all just kind of connected by
their tails and they're just flinging
around all that kind of stuff no I mean
in a sense that like they start meshing
together right like melding together
creating this kind of central spiral and
when the question is like what's the
point of this a beam is kind of fired
out this spire you know out into out
into space when you have file of L and
you have moon dragon making their way
towards the Kree homeworld after being
warned by this disembodied voice and
then finding like this cruiser has
essentially been cut in half
suddenly this voice starts to pop up
again and this voice starts saying like
only you can save them only you could
protect them that kind of a thing you
have to go find the Savior you have to
find the person you have to you have to
find him you have to find that
individual that's going to save
everybody
right and then she's immediately given
cosmic awareness and misses something
that phyla devil did not have before now
cosmic awareness flows you guys who
don't know is the ability to know
everything that's going on in the
universe at that particular point in
time when she receives this gift she
passes out and rightfully so right
because it's a huge amount of
information being given to someone at
one time and only those individuals who
are exceedingly capable of being able to
accept it right but have some kind of
mental conditioning or have some kind of
telepathic or you know some sort of
ability that allows them to withstand
that full mass of information or able to
handle it otherwise it would drive you
insane and throw you into a catatonic
state your brain would literally just
overload and shut down right it would
just be like flipping a switch right
tripping a breaker that's exactly what
that would be and so as a result of that
file of they'll kind of collapses she
doesn't go into a catatonic state she's
gonna be fine for the most part but what
you end up also having here is that an
initially word seemed like it was a gala
Dorian space Knights who were taking
over the centuries and you have Peter
quill here who ends up talking with with
with ten core this this one particular
woman who was hitting on basically you
know trying to get her between the
sheets and where it's kind of like her
and a few of the other Kree soldiers are
there as backup and it's like okay like
we can band together we can take this
out essentially she and the other Kree
have been taken over as well so this
kind of battlenet software is not just
infecting uh you know technological
organisms right it's not it is like
Skynet but not exactly right Skynet only
affected like software right and then
just basically you know once it became
self-aware took over like all computer
systems and then machinery developing
plants and then started creating
terminators and things like that this is
an answer to the question what is Skynet
to take over people and that's exactly
what's going on here they're like they
immediately start opening fire on Peter
quill the guy flees for his life and
then you basically have like all these
pre soldiers who have been taken over by
the by the battlenet software you've got
the gallery and space knives and all of
them saying like we must be one we must
all join together there is no there's no
singular consciousness anymore there is
only us there's only the Phalanx but
here's the funny thing about this as
powerful is the Phalanx are is kind of
like this technological organism that
exists to travel from one place to the
next like the Borg from Star Trek and
just conquer the resources and absorb
other people into themselves the Phalanx
are not the one running the show they're
not the ones pulling the strings they're
doing what they're told now who it is
that's having them do all this that's
the big reveal and that's the the most
awesome part of the story but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
come and explain to make sure you guys
at the
a button to become part of the rod port
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later Bruce
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]